- Throughout history, meteorites
have captivated human imagination.
Each one of these stones
from darker worlds has its own story.
And the bigger ones
have changed entire landscapes.
But they also have left
a deep impact on cultures.
Our voyage took us to
wherever large fireballs
have plunged down to Earth.
- It's a very special place for us.
That's where we feel
the presence of our ancestors.
- How might the church react
if NASA detects
a really threatening object
hurtling towards us?
- I'll be honest. We'll pray.
(laughs)
What else can you do?
- Every element in our body
was synthesized in other stars
before it got here.
So, yeah, we're all stardust.
- Meteorites have meaning.
- Whoa! (laughs)
- The task of humanity is to interpret
what that meaning is.
- When a loved one departs
this life to the next,
that transition is done
through the stars.
- We do not know
what in the future is coming at us.
Untold numbers of these voyagers from afar
are still on their way.
- In Himalayan mythology,
there's this idea of
cycles of creation
and destruction of the universe.
A meteor impact can wipe out life,
but also deliver the seeds of life.